did you know Roman suuk from jiujitsu
kaisen is a real person from Japan's
history a long time ago in some Japanese
provinces people pra sua as their
guardian and hero they also said that
he's the one who introduced them to
Buddhism and even worshiped him in
shrines in some of those shrines there's
still to this day a statue of suuk but
that's only one side of the story you
see in a Japanese history book
Chronicles of Japan sua was actually
described as a villain and an enemy of
the emperor and it was even said that he
killed thousands of innocent people so
which version of the events is true well
both let me explain the name romen can
be translated as to- faced in Japanese
which is why it's believed that Suk
actually had two personalities within
him one good and one evil we already
know that sua from jjk is an immoral and
demonic creature so could it be that
we'll also get to see his good side in
the show at some point